ya know the the journey that this book
records is a very it's a public journey
in that it's a work of science
journalism and history but it's also a
personal journey I you know I began with
the typical journalistic curiosity and I
was interviewing people who were
participating in these trials at NYU and
at Johns Hopkins we met in Baltimore
when I was doing a boarding yeah that's
when we first met and I was talking to
people many of whom who were
psychedelically naive who had had these
powerful transformative experiences
there were people who were dying
they were cancer patients in some cases
there were smokers and they were
so-called healthy normals and all of
them were not all of them but about 80%
of them and it had this very powerful
experience that left them changed and as
I talked to them I became intensely
curious about how a molecule could
account for such a psychological shift
you know a complete change in
perspective and but over time I actually
grew to envy the people I was I was
interviewing and that they had had these
big spiritual epiphanies and I've never
had one I had never had one I was kind
of I always thought of myself as kind of
spiritually [ __ ] and and so I got I
got really jealous of them and and
that's when I decided that to write
about this properly I would have to
educate myself and have a series of
psychedelic journeys and that those yeah
they proved to be transformative